[Music]
oh
peace TV the solution for
[Music]
Humanity oh people of the
world can we SP a little jce
[Music]
can we smell
little
oh
children oh people of the
world can we SP a Little
Love Can we SP a little
PR
for children
May the peace blessings and mercy of
Allah subhana tala be on all of you I Dr
Muhammad
n I'm your coordinator for this program
to be telecast live on peace TV and
inshallah on other channels lat later on
before we start the program I'd prefer
to give you all a
background of how this event has come
about the president of the Oxford Union
Mr James
langman invited Dr Zakir NY as one of
the leading
personalities who could put
forward proper views on the topic Islam
and the 21st
century before the presious debating
Society the Oxford
Union which is famous since
1823 for promoting debates and
discussions on vital topics of concern
not only in the Oxford University and
its campus but across the
globe Dr Zakir Nik will inshallah join a
host of internationally famous speakers
including current prime ministers
David
Cameron former British prime ministers
Tony Blair Margaret
tracher and Winson Churchill US
presidents Bill Clinton and jimmmy
Carter scientist Albert Einstein and
famous personalities like Malcolm X the
Dalai Lama Prince Charles and Mother
Teresa and film stars including Clint
Eastwood Pierce brosen
stepen fry and Popstar Michael Jackson
who have addressed the Oxford Union in
areas of their
concern this dialogue and debate is
going to be a very free and open
Affair and will inshallah be telecast
live moment to
moment across the globe over peace TV
and peace TV uru may I
request the technical people to go ahead
to Mr James langman president of the
Oxford
Union to take over and coordinate and
conduct the proceedings of this historic
debate of the Oxford Union the address
by Dr Zakir Nike on the topic Islam and
the 21st century tonight we continue the
society's proud tradition of inviting
and hosting some of the world's leading
figures to address us we exist as a
society to promote debate and the
discussion of ideas and tonight is no
exception I urge all of you here this
evening to make full use of the question
and answer session that will happen
later on
tonight with that said I now ask you to
join with me in welcoming Dr Zach Nike
to address the society
[Applause]
alhamdulillah
honorable Mr President of the Oxford
Union Mr James langman The Honorable
members of the Oxford Union the
respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all all of you
with the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of you it's an honor and a
great pleasure for me to address this
historic Oxford
Union and I would like to thank the
Oxford Union especially its
president Mr James langman for making
this event possible
the topic of my talk today is Islam and
the 21st
century Islam comes from the root toward
Salam which means peace it's also
derived from the Arabic word FM which
means to submit your will to almighty
God Islam in short means peace acquired
by submitting of to almighty God and any
person
who submits theil to almighty God he is
called as a
Muslim many people have a
misconception that Islam is a new
religion which came into existence 1400
years ago and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is the founder of this
religion in fact Islam is there since
time immemorial since man set foot on
this Earth and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is not the founder of of this
religion but he is the last and final
messenger of almighty
God the religion of Islam is based on
the teachings of the Glorious Quran
which came into existence 400 years
back is it possible that today the
humanity at large in this 21st century
can gain guidance how a life should be
led from a book which is 400 years old
but natural the answer obviously is no
if this book is written by human being
but the Glorious Quran is the last and
final revelation of almighty God which
was revealed to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him the Glorious Quran is the
proclamation to humanity it is the
Fountain of mercy and wisdom it's a
guide to the erring it's a warning to
the heedless it's and Assurance to those
in doubt it's a Solace to the suffering
and it is an hope to those in despair
the Glorious Quran is the last and final
revelation of almighty God which was
revealed to the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him for
any book to claim that it is a word of
God for any book to prove that it is the
Revelation from almighty God it should
stand the test of
time previously in the olden days it was
called the age of
Miracles the Glorious Quran is the
Miracle of Miracles later on came the
age of literature and poetry Muslim and
non-muslim Arabic Scholars alike they
Acclaim the Glorious Quran to be the
best Arabic literature available on the
face of the Earth but today if a
religious book in a very poetic fashion
says the World is Flat will a modern man
believe in it but naturally the answer
is no because today is not the age of
literature and poetry today is the age
of science and technology so let us
analyze whether this glorious Quran is
compatible or incompatible with modern
science according to Albert Einstein the
famous physicist and the Nobel Prize
winner who I'm told also addressed this
historic Oxford Union he said science
without religion is lame
and religion without science is
blind let me remind you the Glorious
Quran is not a book of signs s c i e n c
e but it's a book of signs s i g NS it's
a book of ayats it's a book of verses
and the Glorious Quran has more than
6,000 signs 6,000 ayats 6,000 verses out
of which more than a thousand speak
about
SS as far as my talk today is concerned
I will only be speaking about scientific
facts I will not be speaking about
scientific hypothesis and theories which
all of us know many a time these
theories and hypothesis take you
turns in the field of
astronomy a few decades earlier in the
1970s there were a group of scientists
who described How the Universe came into
existence for which they got the Nobel
Prize this they called as the big bang
and these scientists said that initially
our universe was one primary nebula then
there was a secondary separation there
was a big bang which gave rise to
galaxies the Stars the planets the Sun
as well as the earth on which we live
this they called as the Big Bang this
what the scientist discovered about 40
years back is mentioned in the Quran
1400 years ago in Sur Amia chapter
number 21 verse number 38 says
do not the unbelievers
see that the heavens and the Earth will
joined together and we cloth them
aunder this big bang which the
scientists discovered recently is
mentioned in the Quran 1400 years
ago previously we human beings we
thought that the world was
flat it was in
1577 when Sir Francis Drake sailed
around the earth that he first time
proved that the earth on which we live
it is spical in shape the Quran mentions
1400 years ago in chapter number 79
verse number
30 and thereafter we have made the Earth
XG shape one of the meaning of d is an
expanse and the Earth is an expanse the
other meaning is derived from the Arabic
word duah which means an egg and today
we know the Earth is not completely
round like a ball it is starting from
the pole it is geosphere in shape and if
we analyze the Arabic word daha doesn't
refer to a normal leg it specifically
refers to the Egg of an ostrich and if
you analyze the Egg of an ostrich is to
geosphere in shape Imagine The Glorious
Quran 14400 years ago says that the
Earth is jeal in shape previously we
thought that the light of the moon was
its own
light recently we have come to know that
the light of the moon is not its own
light but it is a reflected and borrowed
light the Quran says in Surah fan
chapter number 25 verse number 61
blessed is he who has placed the
constellation in the sky and placed
therein Sun a lamp having its own light
and moon having borrowed or reflected
light so the Quran describes the
Moonlight as borrowed or reflected which
we came to know recently in science
recently in science mean 50 years back
100 years back 200 years
back when I was in school I passed my
school in 1982 about 29 years back there
I had learned in science that the sun
though it revoles it does not rotate
about its own access but the Quran
mentions in Sur Amia chapter number 21
verse number
33 it is he who has created the night
and the
day the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in orbit with
its own motion the Quran says the Sun
and the Moon besides revolving it also
rotates about its own axis and today
recently a few decades earlier science
has come to know that the sun rotates
and takes about 25 days to complete fun
rotation which has been Incorporated in
most of the school textbooks throughout
the
world there may be certain Skeptics who
will say it's nothing great that the
Quran speaks about astronomy since the
Arabs were advanced in the field of
astronomy
I do agree that the Arabs were advanced
in the field of astronomy but like to
remind them that the Arabs became
advanced in the field of astronomy a few
hundred years after the Quran was
revealed so it is from the Quran that
the Arabs learned about astronomy and
not the vice
versa in the field of
hydrology we learn in the school about
the water
cycle how the water evaporates from the
ocean forms into clouds moves into
interior falls down as rain and the
water table is replenished this was
first described by Sir Bernard pacy in
the year
1580 the Quran too describes the water
cycle in great detail 1400 years ago the
Quran says the water evaporates from the
ocean forms into clouds the clouds join
they move into the interior they fall
down as rain and the water table is
replenished and the water cycle is
completed the Quran speaks about the
water cycle in great detail in several
places in surum chapter number 39 verse
number 21 in Sur Room chapter number 30
verse number 24 in chapter number 23
verse number 18 in chapter number 15
verse number 22 in Sur chapter number 24
verse number 43 in Surah AR chapter
number 7 verse number 57 in Sur chapter
number 13 verse number 17 in Sur fan
chter number 25 verse number 48 and 49
in Surah F 35 verse number 9 in y
chapter number 36 verse number 34 in
Surah jha chapter number 45 verse number
5 in Surah chapter number 50 verse
number 8 and 9 in Sur chter number 56
verse number 68 to 70 in Sur M 67 verse
number 30 in Sur CH number 86 verse
number 11 I can go on and on giving
references only in the Quran of the
several verses which speak about the
water cycle in great
detail in the field of
oceanography there's a verse in the
Quran
in suran chapter number 25 verse number
53 which says that he has let two bodies
of flowing water one sweet and palatable
and the other salty and bitter though
they meet they not mix there is a
barrier which is forbidden to be
trespassed previously we human beings
knew that there two types of water sweet
and salty but the commentator of the
Quran could not understand what does God
Almighty mean by saying that the these
two waters when they meet they not mix
and there is a barrier which is forming
to be test passed today after Sciences
Advanced we have come to know that
whenever one type of water flows into
the other type of water it loses its
constituents and gets homogenized into
the water it flows this today science
calls as the transitional homogenizing
area which the Quran refers to as Barak
as a barrier and this can be seen in cap
point the southernmost stff of South
Africa
and when we see even the color of the
water between these two types of water
differs and Professor he a very famous
oceanologist he said that this
information came to the human knowledge
recently this book the Quran is
difficult to explain how does it
mentioned 400 years
ago in the field of
biology the Quran says inia chapter
number 21 verse number 30 that we have
created every living thing from water
will you not believe imagine in the
deserts of Arabia the Quran says every
living thing is made from water who
could have believed in it today after
science the advanc we have come to know
that every living being it contain cells
and the basic substance of cell is the
cytoplasm which contains about 80% water
today's science tells us that every
living creature contains 50 to 90% water
in the field of Botany previously we did
not know that even the plants have got
sex as male and
female the Quran says in chapter number
20 verse number 53 that it is he who
sends on water from the sky and with it
brings diverse pairs of plants each
separate from the other the Arabic word
awage meaning pair saying that the
plants have got Sexes male and
female in the field of zoology
the Quran says in Surah Anam chapter
number 6 verse number
38 it is he who has made every animal
that walks on the earth and every bird
that flies in the air to live in
communities like the human beings
today's science agrees that even the
animals and the birds live in
communities like the human beings which
was not known
earlier the Quran speaks about the
lifestyle of the bee in Surah Nel
chapter number 16 verse number 68 and 69
the Quran speaks about the lifestyle of
the
spider in Surah anab chapter number 29
verse number 41 the Quran speaks about
the lifestyle and the communication of
ants in Sur chapter number 27 verse
number 17 and
18 in the field of medicine the Quran
says in Sur Nel chapter number 16 verse
68 and 69 that from the belly of the bee
we give you a drink of varing colors in
which there is healing for mankind it is
recently we have come to know that the
honey that we have is obtained from the
belly of the bee and today science
agrees that there are mild antiseptic
properties in Honey and it is even a
healing for
mankind in the field of physiology the
Quran describes the blood circulation
and the production of milk in a nutshell
in Surah nelter 16 verse number 66 600
years after the Quran was revealed
he made it known to the world about the
production of milk and blood circulation
400 years later that is thousand years
after the Quran was revealed William hav
he made it famous to the Western World
we hear about William hav but we hardly
hear about the name of who 400 years
before William ja spoke about the blood
circulation and the production of
milk in the field of emology the Quran
describes the various embryological
stages of the human development in great
detail in Sur chapter number 23 verse
number 12 to 14 it says that human then
we made it
into that human being is Created from a
minute quantity of fluid then it made it
into alaka that is a leech like
substance then made it into AUD like
lump then made it into bones then
clothed the bones with flesh when this
ver was showed in the early part of the
1980s to Dr Kei Mo who at that time
happened to be the highest Authority in
the field of anatomy and emology he was
the head of the department in the
University of Toronto he said that the
description of the Quran is far superior
to what modern embriology describes
today instead of stage 1 2 3 and he said
that it's not possible that any human
being can mention these things in the
Quran this Quran has to be the word from
almighty God and he has no objection in
accepting Prophet Muhammad as the
messenger of almighty
God time does not permit me to speak a
lot about science I'll just give one
more example which is mentioned in the
Quran the Quran mentions in Surah
chapter number
75 verse number three and four that when
the unbelievers say that how will
almighty God be able to reconstruct our
bones after we are dead we are buried
our bones have got disintegrated on the
day of of judgment how will almighty God
be able to reconstruct our bones
almighty God replies in the Quran and
says tell them almighty God can not only
reconstruct the bones he can even
reconstruct in perfect order the very
tips of the fingers what does Quran mean
by saying God can not only reconstruct
the bones he can even reconstruct and
perfect order the very tips of the
fingers it was in 1880 that s Francis
gold he discovered the fingerprinting
method and he said that no two
fingerprints even in millions of people
identical and today this fingerprinting
method is used by the police to identify
the criminal it's used by CIA by FBI by
the police worldwide this Quran mentions
1400 years
ago Francis Bacon a very famous
philosopher he said little knowledge of
science makes a person an atheist
but indepth knowledge of science makes a
person a believer in God that is the
reason today scientists are not
eliminating God they're eliminating
models of God ill there's no God but
Allah I started my talk by quoting a
verse from Quran from huat chapter
number 49 verse number 13 which says
which means oh humankind we have created
you from a single pair of male and
female and have divided you into Nations
and tribes so that you shall recognize
each other not that you shall despise
each other and the most honored in the
sight of almighty God is the person who
has tawa the criteria for judgment in
the sight of almighty God it's not sex
it's not color it's not wealth it's not
age but it is tawa it is God
Consciousness it piety it is
righteousness the only way one human
being can be superior to the other human
being is by righteousness and by py and
no other
criteria Quran says in Sur Room chapter
number 30 verse number 22 amongst the
signs he has created the heavens and the
earth and the variation in your
languages and color these are signs for
the people who understand
the Quran says he has created the
different variation in the color and the
languages so that those are
knowledgeable people they will know it's
a sign from almighty God this speaks
about the universal Brotherhood that
almighty God has created all the human
beings from a common pair of human
beings Adam and Eve may peace be upon
them and almighty God says in Sur is
chapter number 17 verse number
17 and we have honored the children of
Adam almighty God says in the Quran that
all the children of Adam irrespective
whether they're black or white male or
female whether they're born in UK or
India or USA whichever part of the world
they belong to almighty God has honored
all the children of Adam all the human
beings and Islam does not only speak
about Universal Brotherhood it
practically demonstrates that every
Muslim who follow the religion of Islam
should practically practice it minimum
five times in the day I'm talking about
one of the pillars of Islam that is
Salah which is the prayer and a beloved
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
that when you stand for prayer you
should stand shoulder Tosh shoulder
irrespective whether the person standing
next to you is black or white rich or
poor king or poer when you stand for
prayer you have to stand shoulder Tosh
shoulder this demonstrates the universal
brother every day minimum five times a
day and another example ex is Hajj which
is one of the pillars of Islam that
every rich person who has the means and
who has the health to travel to Makkah
for the pilgrimage should at least do it
once in his lifetime and Hajj is the
biggest annual gathering in the world
where about 3 to 4 million people from
different parts of the world from USA
from Canada from UK from India from
Malaysia from different parts of the
world they gather together in one place
in Makkah and Arafat and they are
dressed in two pieces of unson cloth
which is Right In Color you cannot
identify the person standing next to you
is king or proper and all of them come
on a common
statement here we are oh my Lord here we
are at your service Islam practically
demonstrates Universal
Brotherhood many religions believe that
humankind has been created from a single
pair of Adam and Eve may peace be upon
them both but there are some religions
who put the blame only on Eve for the
downfall of humanity for the origin sin
but if you read the Quran the blame for
disobeying almighty God is equally put
on both Adam and Eve may peace be upon
them the Quran says in Surah AR 7 verse
number 19- 27 Adam and Eve peace be upon
them they are both addressed more than a
dozen
times both of them they disobeyed God
both of them repented and both were
forgiven the blame is equally put on
both of them there is not a single ver
in the Quran which puts the blame only
on Eve however there's one verse in the
Quran in Surah T 20: 1221 which says and
singles out Adam peace be upon him and
says he disobeyed
God but on the whole if you read the
Quran the blame is equally put on both
of them there are some religions who
because they say that woman is the cause
of the downfall of humanity which Islam
doesn't agree some religion say because
of that God punished her and pregnancy
is a curse and Punishment of God on the
woman but in Islam pregnancy uplifts the
woman the Quran says in Surah nter 4
vers number one respect the womb that
bore you the Quran says in Surah lman
chapter number 31 verse number 14 we
have enjoined on the human beings to be
kind to the parents
in travil upon Trav did the mother B
them and in years Twain was the wiing
the Quran repeats the message in Sur
chapter number 46 verse number 15 we
have enjoined on the human beings to be
good to the parents in pain did the
mother bear them and in pain did she
give them birth so pregnancy uplifts a
woman does not degrade
her and a beloved Prophet said it's
mentioned in s bukari s bukari is one of
the collection of the authentic sayings
of the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him it's
mentioned s bukari volume number 8 in
the book of manners chapter number two
Hadith number two a man approaches the
prophet and asked him that who deserves
the maximum companionship and love in
this world Prophet said your mother the
man asked after that who the prophet
repeated your mother the man asked after
that who again the prophet said your
mother the man asked for the fourth time
after that who then the prophet said
your father that means 75% 3/4 of the
companionship goes to the mother 25% 1/4
goes to the father in short the mother
gets the gold medal she gets the silver
medal as well as the bronze medal the
father has to be satisfied with the mere
consolation
price these are the teachings of Islam
which we have to
agree and if we
analyze
Islam gave economic rights to women 1300
years before the Western
World 1400 years ago Islam gave right to
any adult Muslim woman to own or disown
the property without the permission of
anyone else the first time the Western
World gave right for a woman to own or
disown property was in 1870s under the
married woman property act which said
that a married woman adult can own or
disown the property without the
permission of the husband and this act
was later revised
Islam gave economic rights to women 1300
years before the Western World and in
Islam we do not agree with the word
housewife which is used in English
language because we don't consider the
woman to be married to the house to be
called as housewife we prefer calling
her as homaker the person who makes the
home the person who builds the
home though we see that there are many
misconceptions and many people think
that that men and women in Islam are not
equal in fact in Islam men and women are
equal but equality does not mean
identicality they're equal but they are
not identical depending upon the
physiological makeup their psychological
makeup their biological makeup they have
different roles overall men and women
are equal in some aspects the woman she
may have a degree of advantage in some
aspects the men may have a degree of
Advantage let me give you an example
if there are two students in a class
student A and B both of them they come
out first in examination both get 80 out
of 100 when we analyze the answer sheet
that 10
questions which have 10 answers each
carrying 10
marks in answer to question number one
so then a gets n out of 10 so then b
gets s out of 10 in answer to question
number two student b gets 9 out of 10
andent in a he gets seven out of 10 in
all the remaining eight answers both get
eight out of 10 if we add up both get 80
out of 100 the equal but in answer
number one the student a has a degree of
advantage in answer number two student B
has a degree of advantage in the other
aspects both are equal and overall also
they're equal in the same way men and
women in Islam are equal in some aspects
the men have a degree of advantage in
some aspects the women have a degree of
advantage for example if a robber if a
thief enters my house I will not say I
believe in woman liberalization I will
not ask my wife or my daughter to go and
fight since God has given me more
strength it is my duty to fight as the
Quran says in Surah n 4:34 that God has
given more strength to men it is his
duty to protect the woman so in strength
the men have a degree of
advantage and the other example I gave
earlier that where companionship of the
children is concerned for the parents
the women have three times more
companionship as compared to men the
mother has three times more
companionship as compared to father so
here the women have a degree of
Advantage so as I said earlier men and
women in Islam are equal in some aspects
the women have a degree advantage in
some aspect the men have a degree
Advantage the
foundation of the religion of
Islam is the belief in one and only
soulle Creator and sustainer and this
Creator and sustainer almighty God is
the same for all the human beings only
if you agree that our creator sustainer
and cherisher one God is the same then
only can Brotherhood be maintained in
all religions and this is the basis of
all the
religions religion according to talks
for dis any means a belief in a
superhuman controlling power a personal
God or gods that deserve worship and
obedience so according to O dictionary
religion means belief in God if you
understand God you understand that
religion in the right
perspective Quran says in Iman 3 vers
number
64 come to Common terms as between us
and you which is the first term
Allah that you worship none but one
almighty God so the Quran says let the
people of different religions come to
Common terms what is different we can
discuss tomorrow let us agree to follow
what is common and one thing common in
all the religion is to believe and
worship only one
God to understand any religion or to
understand the concept of God in a
religion it is not appropriate to try
and observe the follow of that religion
because many of time the followers
themselves may not be aware about the
religion or the concept of the god in
religion the best and the most authentic
way of understanding a religion or
understanding the concept of God in any
religion is to try and understand what
the authentic scriptures of that
religion have to speak about
god let's try and understand the concept
of God in the major religions in the
nutshell first we try understand the
concept of God in
Hinduism the two major and most
authentic scriptures in the religion of
Hinduism are the vas
andish it's mentioned in the chandad
chapter number six section number two
verse number
one God is only one without a second
this is a Sanskrit quotation it's
mentioned in
the chapter number 6 verse number
n J Chad of that God he has got no
parents he has got no Lord he has got no
father he has got no mother he has got
no
Superior it's mentioned in the P chapter
number 4 vers number 19 as well as
chapter number 32 vers number
three of that God there is no pratima
pratima is a Sanskrit word which means
an image a photograph a painting a
picture a sculpture a statue an idol it
says of that God there is no image there
is no picture there is no painting there
is no portrait there is no statue
there's no Idol there's no
sculpture and the Brahma Sutra of
Hinduism the fundamental Creed of
Hinduism
isah there's only one God not a second
one not at all not at all not in the
least bit so if you read the Hindu
scripture you should understand the
concept of God in Hinduism and
understand Hinduism in the right
perspective let's discuss the concept of
God in Judaism it's mentioned in the Old
Testament in the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 6 verse number four Moses
peace be upon Him
says is the Lord our God is one Lord
It's mentioned in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 43 Verse number 11 I
I Am Lord and there's no savior besides
me it's mentioned in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 45 verse number five I Am
Lord and there's none else there's no
God besides me it's mentioned in the
book of Isaiah chapter number 46 verse
number N I am God and there's none else
I am God and there's none like me it's
further mentioned in the book of Exodus
chapter number 20 verse number 3 to 5 as
well as in the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 5 verse number
79 almighty God says thou shall have no
other God besides me thou shall not make
unto thee any Graven image of anything
of any likeness in the heaven above in
the earth beneath in the water beneath
the Earth thou shall not bow down to
them nor serve them for thy God thy Lord
is a jealous God so if you read the Old
Testament you should understand the
concept of God in Judaism and understand
Judaism in the right
perspective before we discuss discuss
the concept of God in Christianity I
would like to clarify a few points Islam
is the only non-Christian Faith which
makes it an Article of Faith to believe
in Jesus Christ peace be upon him no
muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him we believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of almighty God we
believe he was the Messiah transcended
Christ we believe that he was born
miraculously without any male
Intervention which many modern day
Christians today not believe we believe
that he gave life to the Dead with God's
permission we believe he healed those
born blind and lepers with God's
permission the Christians and the
Muslims we are going together one may
ask then where is The Parting of V The
Parting of V is that many Christians
believe or most of the Christians
believe that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him he claimed Divinity they believe
that he was almighty God in fact if you
read the Bible there is not a sing
single unequivocal statement there is
not a single unambiguous
statement in the complete Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be upon him himself
says that I am God always says worship
me in fact if you read the Bible it's
mentioned in the Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 28 Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said my father is
greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than All gospel of Matthew
chapter number 12 verse number 28 I cast
out Devils with the spirit of God Gospel
of Luke chapter number 11 verse number
20 I with the Finger of God cast out
Devils Gospel of John chapter number 5
verse number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of my father anyone who
says I seek not my will but the will of
almighty God he's a Muslim as I
mentioned Muslim means a person who
submits a will to God and Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said not my will but
the will of almighty God so in Arabic we
say Muslim therefore we say Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was one of the
mightiest messengers of almighty God and
he further clarified in the Gospel of
John chapter number 14 verse number 24
he said that the words that you he are
not mine but my fathers who has sent me
it's mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 17 verse number 3 Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said this is
life eternal so that you may know one
true God and Jesus Christ whom thou has
sent it's clearly mentioned in the book
of Acts chapter number 2 verse number 22
it says aen of Israel listen to this
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst You by wers and miracles and
signs which God did by him and you are
witness to it a man approved of God
amongst You by wonders and miracles and
signs which God did by and you witness
to it and when Jesus Christ peace be
upon him was asked that which is the
first of The Commandments he repeated
verit what was said by Moses peace be
upon him earlier it's mentioned in the
gospel of Mark chapter number 12 verse
number 29 Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said which means is the Lord our God is
one Lord so if you read the Bible you
should understand the concept of God in
Christianity and understand Christianity
in the right
perspective let's discuss the concept of
God in Islam the best reply that any
Muslim can give you regarding the
concept of God in Islam is quote to you
surlas that is chapter number 112 verse
number 1 to 4 which says
say he's Allah one and only Allah Allah
the absolute and
eternal he begs not know he
begotten they nothing like him this is a
four-line definition of almighty God any
person says so and so candidate is God
if he passes these four test we Muslims
have got no objection in accepting as
God the first is say he's one and only
the second is he should be absolute and
eternal the third he begets not know he
he begotten and fourth that nothing like
unto him anything in this
world this is a four-line definition of
almighty God which we call as the liment
test for theology it is the touchone of
Theology and further the Quran says in
Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse number
108 that revile not abuse not those God
who they worship besides Allah lest in
the ignorance they will revile they will
abuse Allah subhana wa tala Quran
prohibits any Muslim
from speaking bad from reviling from
abusing those who other people worship
as God besides Allah lest in the
ignorance they will abuse
Allah so to understand the concept of
God in Islam you have to read the
Quran today unfortunately Islam is the
most misunderstood religion in the
world the religion which has the maximum
misconception in the world today it is
Islam
and one of the reasons for these
misconceptions about this
religion I would say it is the
media today we find in the international
media there is virent propaganda
regarding Islam we find in the
international newspapers in the
International magazine on the radio
broadcast stations on the Internet
satellite channels on the internet there
is virent propaganda regarding
Islam and the most misunderstood word
regarding Islam it is the word Jihad it
is not only misunderstood by the Muslims
because of the media it's also
misunderstood by the non-muslims today
most of the people whether they are
Muslims or non-muslim they think that
any War fought by any Muslim for any
reason whether it be for personal gain
whether it be for name whether it be for
fame whether it be for Honor whether it
be for land any War fought by any Muslim
is called as Jihad
Jihad does not mean any War fought by
any Muslim for any reason Jihad comes
from the Arabic word jihada which means
to strive which means to struggle in the
Islamic context Jihad means to strive
and struggle against one's own evil
inclination Jad also means to strive and
struggle to make the society better Jad
also means to strive and struggle
against oppression Jad also means to
strive and struggle in self-defense so
Jihad basically means to strive and
struggle for example if a student is
striving and struggling to pass in the
examination in Arabic we'll say he's
doing
Jihad so Jihad basically means to stve
and struggle today most of the
orientalist they
translate the word Jihad as holy
war if you translate holy war into
Arabic it is Hara and this word
appears nowhere in the Quran nowhere in
any saying of the Prophet Muhammad s
wasallam this word holy word if you go
back into history was first used for the
Crusades when the Crusaders they forced
people to accept the religion of
Christianity by force and unfortunately
today it is used for the Muslims and
Islam Quran mentions explicitly in Surah
MAA chapter number 5 verse number 32 do
if
anyone kills any other human being
unless it be for murder or for spreading
corruption in the land it is as though
he has killed the whole of humanity the
Quran says if any human being kills any
other innocent human being whether
Muslim or non-muslim it is as though he
has killed the whole of humanity and the
verse continues if anyone saves in human
being whether Muslim or non-muslim it is
as though he has saved the whole of
humanity
I being a student of comparative
religion I have not come across any
verse in any Scripture besides the Quran
which is so explicit against terrorism
against killing innocent human beings it
says that if any human being kills any
other human being who's innocent whether
Muslim or non-muslim it is as though you
have killed the whole of humanity and I
not come across any verse in any other
scripture any other religious scripture
besides the Quran which promotes the
prevention of terrorism and it says if
any human being saves any human life
whether Muslim or non-muslim it is as
though you have saved the whole of
humankind Islam condemns all forms of
terrorism Islam condemns the killing of
any innocent human being irrespective of
cast color creed irrespective of which
nationality belongs to irrespective
which religion it belongs to Islam and I
to condemn all forms of
terrorism I also condemn the
911 which took place on 11th of
September 2001 the Twin Tower bombing in
New York where few thousand innocent
people were killed I condemn the 77 7th
of July
2005 London bombing where more than 50
innocent people were killed I also
condemn the serial train Bomb Blast that
took place in Bombay on the 11th of July
2006 where more than 180 innocent people
were killed I also condemn the Gujarat
Massacre the riots which were ple planed
which took place in Gujarat in India
where innocent few thousand Muslims were
killed I condemn all sorts of terrorism
where innocent human beings are killed
irrespective whether Muslim or
non-muslim and whatever acts of
terrorism with takes the life of
innocent human being is to be condemned
including suicide bombing now we have
recent in the past few
decades that a person goes he puts up a
bomb goes in a
Marketplace goes in a tube station on
the road and he blows himself up and
with him takes several other human lives
this act is not tolerable in any
religion especially Islam suicide
bombing where innocent human beings are
killed is totally prohibited in
Islam unfortunately
though Islam is a religion which
condemns all sorts of terrorism all acts
of terrorism took place in the past
which is even taking place in this 21st
century even though it condemns
Unfortunately today the media portrays
Islam as a religion which promotes
terrorism every Community has its black
ship and I'm also aware that there are
black sheep in the Muslim Community
what does the media do the media picks
up the black sheep of the Muslim
Community and the portray as though they
exemp pre
Muslims because of this today we find
that most of the people think that Islam
promotes terrorism if you read the Quran
if you read the sayings of the Prophet
Islam amongst all the religions is at
the foremost in condemning the killing
of innoc and human beings